[موسيقى]
تحضر برنامجنا ويلي يقول ما يتخفى لغه
اللغه ما يتخفى لغه اللغه وداعوا المعنى
اللي يصير كيف اللغه تعطيك تعطيك صوره
وتعطيك اتجاه لكن لا تحدد لك ماهيه الصوره
الذهن هو اللي يفتحها فتفتح الافق يعني
مثلا انا لو عملت مشهد امامي واصور
وكراسام وانا رسام امانه حتى لكن عندما
ارسم فهي الصوره محدده امامي المثير لكن
اللغه تعطيني الطريق
[موسيقى]
يسعل الفن اسعل الجمال اسعل الحريه اسعى
الى التعريف بالحرف العربي كمنجز بصري خاص
ويحمل هويه ويحمل بطياته تراث خلينا نقول
تراث متعدد وليس فقط يرتبط باللغه لان
اللغه هي هي قول احدى اقوال الحرب لكن
الحرف كمنجز بصري هو منجز متكامل له لغه
يخاطب فيها الجمال يخاطب فيها الشعوب
[موسيقى]
حروفها البارد والحار فيها اليابس واللين
وفيها حسب
الكواكب مثلا فيها حروف مثلا شمسيه وحروف
قمريه وحروف هوائيه وترابيه وحسب الابراج
جميل جميل قد تكون اللغه العربيه والحرف
العربي هو الوحيد اللي عنده هذه الابعاد
والدلالات وابعد من ذلك هناك مقاربات بين
الموسيقى والحرف وهناك مقاربات ايضا بين
الشعر وبحوره والحرف
فبنتيجه هو مستودع وخزان كبير لهذا الشيء
يعني تخيل بصريا بصريا عندما نقول
نكتب شيء عن الحب نتجه لحروف معينه لنوع
خط معين عندما نكتب عن الحكمه لخط اخر
[موسيقى]
اذا تكلمنا عن اللغه فهي لغه صوتيه وهي
لغه تصويريه بنفس الوقت بقيه اللغات
العالم لا تحمل هذا الثقل وهذا التنوع
بالدلالات يعني عندما مثلا تسمع كلامه
والو انه كلام كرر كثيرا لما قال بيكاسو
اردت الوصول الى اقصى نقطه في فن الرسم
وجدت الخط العربي سبقني اليها منذ امر
بعيد
[موسيقى]